ian anderson jeff back off the injured
list verbatim starting for the first
time since july the 11th yeah you hope i
know it's right shoulder but with six
weeks off that he's feeling good as you
said just good to have him back in the
rotation taking the
ball this one popped up on the infield
who wants it freddy freeman takes over
at first base
and that takes care of wade who's now
one for eight in the series in atlanta
good start for anderson soft contact
soft contact again riley the rover gets
a good look and takes care of la stella
two quick outs
swinging a fly ball hit toward left but
rosario is there his first start as a
brave and anderson is back from the
injured list long inning but a scoreless
inning giant strand of pair of the
braves offense goes to work well anthony
di slovani first starts since august
18th not a long time out but that right
ankle's been giving him some problems
and it was a very short start on august
18th we'll see how he does today and
he's been a road warrior coming off to
that 25th start really pitch well away
from oracle park 280 r8 and 14 starts
200 batting average against
o2
slider on the ground to second
stella throws out ozzy alves
2-2 pitch and a fast ball grounded to
the left side moving to his left flores
has it a throw on the run to first and
it's in time
on the ground at a hard slider to belt
who's going to take it himself for out
number three that was an excellent
beginning for anthony diesel the ankle
looks good no score we go to inning
number two
and that one's smashed towards short
short hop and that'll be an easy turn
no man's land for yastrimsky
kosali hit it right on the button but
the braves get a double play to end a
very quick
san francisco second atlanta's infield
defense has been great all year nice
pick nice turn nice result no score home
second coming up
late dancing off third the pitch is
right back where it came from it knocked
his glove off ozzy's throw to first is
in time that'll end the inning is
anderson all right
i think he said it got his jersey top on
the way by a screaming mimi back through
the box
and that jersey slowed the ball down
enough
for ozzy albies to recover
and now eddie rosario making his first
start as a brave he can get something
started
as this one's poked off the end of the
bat that might find some green grass his
first hit is a brave
a single to center
first runner in scoring position for
atlanta strike three swinging
got him to chase in the dirt strike
three swinging now he's saying he got a
piece of it but the answer to that plea
is no sorry ozzie three straight
strikeouts from diesel funny after the
lead off hit
slow roller right at freddy freeman
thank you very much and ian anderson
works around that lead-off hit seven
ground ball outs for him now the braves
bats are trying to give him some runs
jorge solaire will lead things off
swing and a drive look how far that
one's gonna go
way over the bullpen way up into the
hank aaron terrace
jorge solaire with a monster for his
20th home run
and the braves lead it one to nothing
and that is a hanging slider
austin reilly with an rbi chance runner
in second and still nobody out in the
braves fourth inning
swaying at a drive that ball is golfed
on one iron wow two-run home run for
austin riley
and it's three to nothing braves
he'd got him off that's how he struck
him out the first time almost struck him
out this ab up
well he missed down and austin riley if
that didn't go over the wall jeff that
would have gone through the wall
dave greshner is coming out
along with gabe kepler i mean i i
figured he might be done no matter what
he's looking down at that ankle
so i think i think gabe's already
decided diesel funny is coming out of
the game so dee stefani is coming out
and sammy long will be coming in braves
now will face the left-hander sammy long
and he's going to face eddie rosario
with runners at first and second nobody
out
rosario somehow got the bat on that ball
brandon belt catches it for out number
one
got him big out number two sammy long's
gotten a couple out since coming in the
game use the chain job 2-2 change-up
1-2 to anderson a swing and a round ball
on one hop right to second picking it up
there la stella nice work there from
sammy long
retires three in a row
and the inning comes to a club so rough
at first now two outs
and vote can't find it and ruff's going
to take off and he'll reach standing up
at second and that's going to be the end
of the line so
no visit from rekranitz it's brian
snitker going to take the ball for me
and anderson it was terrific five and
two thirds innings of two walk
four hit shutout baseball you got to set
up matson get this he can pitch his
seventh here it is
did he go
yes he did flores is out on a check
swing
and matching works around
a couple of walks
the bracing push a couple across right
here might be able to kind of ice this
thing away to be honest with you rosario
has singled stolen a base and lined out
hammered into the right field corner
that's going to score one for sure
dansby around second on his way to third
wash is gonna wave him he's gonna score
they miss the cut-off man and rosario
slides in with a two-run triple five to
nothing atlanta
that nine game trip this one's queued
off the pitcher's foot
crawford bad hop throws to first night
in time and all the bounces are going
the braves way today
so runners at the corners with nobody
out and freeman at the plate
there's a shot in the center freddie
freeman has a hit and an rbi
all bees will score and the braves have
made it six nothing
and the pinch
swinging a fly ball left center field
tracking is rough the left fielder
coming over as yostrimski it'll be rough
for the catch tagging it third and
coming home to score is solaire it's
seven to nothing on the sacrifice fly by
jack peterson
high towering fly ball to left rough on
the run glasses gleaming not gonna get
it
home run number 23 for all bees
and makes it a nine nothing game
on the ground tricky hop dansby stayed
with it how about you braves they take
two out of three from the giants
[Applause]
and they return the shutout favor last
night san francisco picked up their 15th
today the braves earned their 15th
shutout the brewers and giants and
braves all bunched up tied for first in
that regard jeff all three of those
teams perhaps headed for the playoffs